[Music]  I'd like to make an announcement  divorce Castle we're not going to be  your home this year but home to some  very special guests as well lovely  ladies of battements I was just  wondering if maybe he wanted to go to  the ball with me miss Teresa place your  right hand on my waist  [Music]  I'm on Ukraine Jeff with Viktor Krum  you're finalizing with the enemy the  enemy Hogwarts has been chosen to host a  legendary event the Triwizard Tournament  [Music]  I didn't put my name in that Cup  I don't want kernel flooring  it's not a murder killing cars only one  person is known to have survived at  they're sitting in this room people die  in this tournament  the temples are inside the walls  [Music]  it's always coming closer the dark will  arise okay  is it Voldemort  [Music]  [Music]  everything's going to change now isn't  it  [Music]  [Music]